Stuart Varney: Socialism
leads to decline and ruin.
Bernie Sanders: They may
hate democratic socialism.
Sean Hannity: And they
think we, the people,
are stupid, helpless, uneducated.
Sanders: But they absolutely
love corporate socialism.
Donald Trump: We will never
be a socialist country.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Manny Fidel: The back-and-forth between
Republicans and Democrats on socialism
is enough to give you whiplash.
But one thing is true:
socialism is on the rise.
Forty-three percent of Americans now say
that some form of socialism
is good for the country,
compared to just 25% in 1942.
Comrades are popping up like
Starbucks all over America.
As much as Republicans hate this,
it turns out they have
themselves to thank.
It is their own policies
and actions that have
positioned democratic socialism
as a legitimate option for Americans.
Congratulations; you've played yourself.
Here's the trend.
Republicans dismantle
moderate liberal policies.
They attack those policies as socialism
and institute their own far-right ideas.
That causes Democrats to respond
with an even more left-leaning proposal.
And because of that back-and-forth,
more Americans are now considering
giving some form of socialism a chance.
Herman Cain: The C in capitalism
stands for competition.
The S in socialism
stands for state control.
Fidel: The S here actually
stands for straw man,
because the type of socialism
that Republicans are attacking
isn't quite the same as the one that
progressives are pushing for.
Traditional socialism pushes
for collective ownership
of all means of production,
either through direct ownership by workers
or the government.
Democratic socialism is the idea
that the government should provide
just the basic needs for its citizens,
like healthcare, education, and more.
This is the type of
socialism being promoted
by politicians like Sen. Bernie Sanders
and Rep. Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
Now, Republicans love
to scream "socialism"
at any policy that
involves the government.
They'd probably call their kids socialists
if they asked for an allowance.
But remember, it's Republican
policy that contributed
to the rise of Democratic
socialism in the first place.
Obamacare is the perfect example.
It was passed in 2010, and
literally minutes later,
a group of Republicans filed a lawsuit
against it, saying it was
Because Obamacare mandated
that people sign up for
healthcare or pay a fee,
Republicans started calling
it a government takeover,
likening it to socialism.
Mike Pence: And the
American people don't want
a government takeover of healthcare.
Fidel: They immediately
obstructed enrollment efforts
by passing laws intended
to limit and defund
Obamacare outreach.
Fourteen red states eventually dropped out
of Obamacare's Medicaid expansion,
leaving an estimated 3.6
million people uninsured.
In 2017, Republicans wanted
to repeal Obamacare's rule
that people have to sign up
for healthcare or pay a fee.
The Congressional Budget Office
predicted that if they
succeeded in doing this,
many people would lose healthcare
and the amount people pay
per month would go up.
Republicans repealed the rule anyways,
and, of course, that
helps keep premiums high.
People started getting
tired of the current system.
In 2018, 79% of Americans
were dissatisfied
with the total cost of healthcare.
They're looking for relief,
and the most ambitious and
appealing alternative is:
Kirsten Gillibrand: Medicare for All.
Michael Bennet: Medicare for All.
Sanders: Medicare for All.
Fidel: "Medicare for All"
is a proposal that says
the government should
be providing Medicare
not just for those over 65 years old,
but for everyone.
In fact, even moderate Democrats
are pushing for what's
called the "public option,"
a proposal for a government-run
healthcare alternative
that would compete with private insurers.
But even modest reforms
like the public option
are being blasted as
"socialist" by Republicans.
Meridian Paulton: You know,
the public option is just
a Trojan horse for government-run
healthcare across the map,
for socialist healthcare.
Fidel: Because Republicans have been
calling everything socialism forever,
Americans found themselves
defining socialism
as something different
than the traditional form.
Since 1949, fewer people think socialism
is about government control
and more people think
socialism is about equality,
benefits, services, and Medicare for All.
Even though Republicans
contributed to the situation
that made Medicare for
All a legitimate proposal,
you can probably guess
how they feel about it.
Katrina Pierson: I think we're
past insanity at this point.
Charlie Kirk: It is so beyond realistic,
it's almost not even worthy
of even analyzing the policy.
Jesse Watters: Now, let's look
at the facts about socialism,
shall we?
Venezuela. Sick people
are taking dog medicine.
Fidel: Another example of Republicans
contributing to socialism's popularity:
the Green New Deal.
In the years leading up to
the Trump administration,
progressive efforts for the environment
were looking relatively good.
Activists were halting the construction
of harmful pipelines across America,
the world became more
aware of climate change,
and the Obama administration
opted into the Paris accord,
a legally binding agreement
that aims to limit global warming.
However, when Trump became president,
the country did a one-eighty
on environmental policy.
Trump signed orders that advanced
the Keystone and Dakota Access pipelines
that Native Americans said
threatened water resources
and sacred sites.
Republicans passed the
resolution allowing for
mining waste to be dumped in streams.
Trump appointed Scott
Pruitt, of all people,
to lead the Environmental
Protection Agency.
Pruitt repeatedly sued the EPA
while he was Oklahoma's attorney general,
and when Pruitt resigned from the post,
Trump replaced him with
a former coal lobbyist.
Sanders: Scientific community
has said that climate change
is one of the great
crises facing our planet.
Andrew Wheeler: I would not
call it the greatest crisis,
no sir.
Fidel: In June 2017,
Trump pulled out of the Paris
accord I mentioned earlier.
I think you get the point.
This made it clear to progressives
that Republican views on climate change
were detrimental to the environment.
Then, in February 2019,
AOC introduced the Green New Deal,
a massively ambitious
plan to curb bad emissions
and create jobs in
clean energy industries.
It's a response to the
Trump administration's
callous actions towards the environment,
and it's pretty popular.
Sixty-three percent of adults believe that
the Green New Deal is a good idea,
and 83% of Democrats agree.
So, once again, even though
Republicans contributed
to the situation that
led to this proposal,
you can guess how they feel about it.
Steve Hilton: It's really extreme.
They are actually talking about
controlling the entire economy.
Sara Carter: It requires
people to turn on each other
and for a government to
answer for everything.
Fidel: These attacks aren't new, either.
Let's go back in time a bit.
During the Great Depression,
FDR was working to pass the New Deal,
a series of public programs
created to provide financial
aid to the country.
But wealthy businessmen,
aka people who didn't want the government
to play a larger role in their lives,
opposed the deal and formed a new party.
The American Liberty League
was so against the New Deal
that they compared it to
policies from the Soviet Union.
(clears throat)
In the following decades,
this tactic went on to
become a Republican favorite.
Sebastian Gorka: You
are on the front lines
of the war against communism
coming back to America
under the guise of democratic socialism.
Frank Luntz: If you're a young person
and you tell someone of the opposite sex
that you're a socialist,
you're much more likely to get some action
at the end of the evening.
(laughs)
Fidel: Before I go
update my Tinder profile,
I'll give you one more reason
why socialism is on the rise in America.
It's simply because, politically speaking,
Trump's policies have brought
us so far to the right,
it only makes sense that
new opposition to Trump
would come from the far left.
This is how two democratic socialists
were elected to Congress in 2018,
and it might be what gives
Bernie Sanders more steam
heading into the election.
Today's political issues
are complicated and nuanced.
If the Republicans'
solutions to those issues
only benefit those at the
top, you can't blame voters
for looking for more radical alternatives.
Godless union of the Soviet.
I accidentally sounded like
Bernie Sanders there. (laughs)